Dies ist ein Film über
die wahren Helden am Mount Everest,
dem mit 8'850 m.ü.M.
höchsten Berg der Welt:
die Sherpas.
Sie ermöglichen den westlichen
Bergsteigern den Traum vom Gipfel,
tragen ihre Lasten
und bereiten ihnen den Weg.
Unsere Helden sind Norbu, ein
29-jähriger Sherpa aus Kathmandu,
am Anfang seiner Karriere.
Für mich geht es nicht nur ums Geld.
Ich wollte schon immer mal
auf dem Gipfel stehen.
Und Long Dorje,
mit 42 Jahren eine Legende.
Er stand 13-mal auf dem Gipfel
des Everest.
Mit dem Einkommen einer Expedition
ernähre ich meine Familie
ein ganzes Jahr lang.
Daher muss ich als Sherpa arbeiten.
Dieser Film zeigt das Leben der
Sherpas und ihre Arbeit am Everest.
Es ist die Geschichte
über ihren verdienten Gipfelerfolg,
aber auch ein Film
über Leben und Tod,
der zeigt, wie sich die Sherpas
für das Leben der Kunden aufopfern
und sich so selber
in Todesgefahr bringen.
(Über Funk)
Es ist Ende März im Dörfchen Thamo
auf 3'490 m.ü.M.
Die Sherpas sind ein Volksstamm,
der vor 500 Jahren von Tibet
nach Nepal zog.
Sie sprechen
einen tibetischen Dialekt,
leben von der Landwirtschaft,
haben aber schnell begriffen,
dass mit westlichen Expeditionen
mehr Geld zu verdienen ist.
So auch Long Dorje, der seiner Frau
auf dem Feld hilft.
Sein Vater starb bereits früh.
Ich weiss wenig von meinem Vater.
Er war auch
im Trekking-Business tätig.
Meine Mutter blieb daheim
und erledigte die Hausarbeit.
Wir hatten auch Yaks, die wir im
Sommer auf die Hochweiden brachten
und im Winter bei uns hielten.
Meine Mutter verkaufte Butter
und Joghurt.
Long Dorje hat es dank seiner Stärke
und Körpergrösse weit gebracht.
Dorje, how are you?
- Fine.
Seine 13 Everest-Erfolge beeindrucken
sowohl den buddhistischen Lama,
wie auch die einfachen Bauern.
Die buddhistische Religion spielt im
Leben der Sherpas eine grosse Rolle.
So bekommt der Lama eine kleine Gabe
und einen Glücksschal.
Dorje lebt mit seiner Frau
Pasang Tiki in seinem Elternhaus.
Mit dem Geld aus den Expeditionen
schicken sie ihre beiden Töchter
nach Kathmandu in die Schule.
Sie hoffen, dass diese dadurch
ein besseres Leben führen,
ja vielleicht sogar
ins Ausland ziehen können.
Long Dorje leidet darunter,
dass er keine Schulbildung bekam.
Er musste früh Verantwortung
für die Familie übernehmen.
Es gab viele Gründe,
warum ich nicht studieren konnte.
Meine Brüder gingen in die Schule.
Ich nicht.
Ich musste das Vieh hüten.
Dann nahm der älteste Bruder
meine zwei jüngeren Brüder
nach Kathmandu mit.
Und ich blieb alleine zu Hause.
Niemand half mir.
Ich wuchs mit den Yaks
auf den Alpweiden auf.
Dann wurde ich Träger
für verschiedene Trekking-Gruppen
und lernte Leute kennen.
So gewann ich Erfahrungen
in diesem Beruf.
Und da ich stark und schlau war,
habe ich auch
meine Arbeit gut verrichtet.
Die meisten Leute
haben mich gerne angestellt.
Seine beiden Brüder leben heute
dank ihrer Ausbildung in Amerika.
Long Dorje
blieb das einfache Leben von Thamo.
Hier feiert die Hochzeitsgesellschaft
seiner Nichte in seinem Haus.
* Gesang *
Durch das Bergsteigen erreichte Dorje
Berühmtheit und Wohlstand.
Kathmandu -
die hektische Hauptstadt Nepals.
Mit über 1,2 Mio. Einwohnern
ist sie das Zentrum des Landes.
Es ist ein Schmelztiegel
vieler Kulturen und Religionen.
Hier befindet sich die grösste,
buddhistische Stupa Nepals,
der Bodnath-Tempel.
Norbu Sherpa lebt in Kathmandu.
Als Kind schickte ihn seine Familie
zu einer Tante nach Darjeeling,
wo er eine gute Ausbildung bekam.
Er versuchte im Ausland einen Job
zu ergattern,
doch er wurde Opfer einer
Schlepperbande, verlor sein Geld
und landete wieder in Kathmandu.
Hier fand er einen Job im Büro
einer Trekking-Agentur,
die mit dem Schweizer Kari Kobler
zusammenarbeitet.
Man lernt viel mehr,
wenn man von Kathmandu aus
zum Bergsteigen geht,
als wenn man im Dorf bleibt.
In Kathmandu
hat man Zugang zu Computern
und so sehr viele Kontakte
zu Ausländern.
Die Büroarbeit
wurde ihm aber bald zu langweilig.
Auf sein Drängen hin bekam er die
Chance, auf Expeditionen mitzugehen.
Zuerst als Küchenjunge, dann als
Hochträger, als sog. Climbing Sherpa.
Climbing Sherpas,
die in Kathmandu leben,
haben gute Möglichkeiten,
Geld zu verdienen
und sich eine bessere Zukunft
aufzubauen.
Norbu möchte nicht ein Leben lang
diesen gefährlichen und anstrengen-
den Job als Climbing Sherpa ausüben.
Er möchte später den Ruhm,
das Geld und seine Kontakte nutzen,
um sich weiterzuentwickeln.
In Long Dorjes Haus
findet wie vor jeder Expedition
eine feierliche Zeremonie,
eine sog. Puja statt.
Die Mönche kommen aus dem
benachbarten buddhistischen Kloster.
Ohne eine Puja würde Long Dorje
nie zum Everest gehen,
den die Sherpas Chomolungma nennen.
Chomolungma ist eine Göttin für uns.
Wir beten zu ihr,
bevor wir aufsteigen.
Wir bitten sie um Erlaubnis
und beten,
dass niemandem etwas passiert.
Wieder einmal
packt Dorje seinen Rucksack
für die nächsten zwei Monate.
Alles Gute und kehre heil zurück!
- Das wünsche ich dir auch.
Überarbeite dich nicht!
- Nun gehe ich.
Pass auf dich auf!
Long Dorjes Frau
ist von nun an zwei Monate allein.
Wenn das Wetter schlecht ist,
mache ich mir Sorgen.
Und wenn Leute vorbeikommen,
will ich immer wissen,
ob sie Neuigkeiten von Dorje
haben.
Wenn mir jemand nicht antwortet,
befürchte ich stets,
dass er mir irgendwelche schlech-
ten Nachrichten vorenthalten will.
Mir geht es erst wieder gut,
wenn er zurück ist.
Es ist Ende März 2008.
Im Flughafen von Kathmandu ist der
Schweizer Bergführer Kari Kobler
mit seinen Expeditionsteilnehmern
gelandet.
Hallo, Dorje!
Long Dorje und andere Sherpas
erwarten ihn.
Kari Kobler führt seit acht Jahren
Expeditionen zum Everest durch.
Er selber stand
schon dreimal auf dem Gipfel.
Er wird von neun
Expeditionsmitgliedern begleitet.
Jeder hat 40'000 Fr. bezahlt,
um sich seinen Traum vom Everest
durch Kari und seine Organisation
erfüllen zu lassen.
Long Dorje nutzt die Zeit,
um sich auch in Kathmandu
von seiner Familie zu verabschieden.
Er trifft sie im Haus
seiner Schwester.
Seine Töchter gehen hier zur Schule.
Die jüngere ist Novizin
in einem Kloster
und die ältere
besucht eine Privatschule.
Ich bin Studentin.
Wenn mich der Lehrer fragt,
was mein Vater mache,
dann sage ich,
dass er Bergsteiger sei.
Wenn mein Vater den Gipfel bezwingt,
bin ich glücklich.
Wenn ich den Beruf meines Vaters
beschreibe, fühle ich mich stolz.
Jeden Morgen bete ich zu Gott,
dass mein Vater Erfolg hat
und heil nach Hause kommt.
An den Abschied
können sie sich nicht gewöhnen.
Zu gross ist die Angst,
dass der Vater einmal
nicht mehr zurückkehren könnte.
Am Fusse des Everest,
auf 5'340 m.ü.M.,
treffen unterdessen
die ersten Sherpas ein.
Es ist eine besondere Gruppe,
die hier den Gletscher betritt:
Ang Nima Sherpa
und seine Eisfalldoktoren.
Ihr Arbeitsplatz ist der gewaltige,
scheinbar unüberwindbare Khumbu-
Eisfall, das Tor zum Everest.
Diese Sherpas
werden zwischen diesen Eistürmen
den Weg für die Expeditionen
vorbereiten.
Ausgerüstet mit Leitern und Seilen
machen sie sich auf
in das Eislabyrinth.
Den Namen "Eisfalldoktoren" bekamen
sie von zwei Everest-Veteranen,
die sie einst
bei ihrer Arbeit beobachteten.
Sie sahen zu, wie wir arbeiteten.
Wir legen die Leitern,
drehen an den Eisschrauben,
schlagen mit dem Eishammer zu
und fixieren die Seile.
Vielleicht hielten sie das
für Arbeit von Doktoren.
Zuerst nannte man uns
"Eisfallarbeiter",
aber dann sagten alle:
"Das sind Eisfalldoktoren."
Bevor ein westlicher Bergsteiger je
einen Fuss in den Eisfall setzt,
beginnen diese Sherpas
ihre gefährliche Arbeit.
Sie verlegen und verankern Seile
und Leitern.
Der Eisfall
bewegt sich je nach Schätzung
zwischen 30 und 100 cm pro Tag.
Der Eisfall ist wie Popcorn:
oben bedeckt von Schnee
und unten offen.
An verschiedenen Stellen hört man
dabei echoähnliche Geräusche.
Dann weiss man, dass hier in den
nächsten Tagen das Eis brechen wird.
Ang Nima kennt den Eisfall
wie kein Zweiter.
Seit 1975 sucht er mit seinem Team
jedes Jahr einen neuen Weg
zwischen
den haushohen Gletschertürmen.
Die Expedition von Kari Kobler
befindet sich im Anflug auf Lukla.
Das Dorf auf 2'860 m.ü.M.
ist Ausgangspunkt
jeder Everest-Expedition.
Auch für die beiden Walliser
Teilnehmer und Bergführer
Patrick Z'Brun und Meinrad Bitel.
... ziemlich das Gesicht verbrennen.
Das ist einerseits sicherlich die
Verwirklichung meines Kindertraums.
Vor 30 Jahren, ich war damals 15,
bestiegen Messner und Habeler
den Everest ohne Sauerstoff.
Ich las die damaligen
Expeditionsberichte unzählige Male.
Und ich erinnere mich
auch heute noch gut an sie.
Das blieb irgendwie hängen.
Vor 25 Jahren, als ich
den Bergführerschein machte,
war mein erster Gedanke:
Ich möchte einmal in meinem Leben
auf 8'000 m.ü.M. stehen.
In den letzten zwei Jahren
hat sich plötzlich
herauskristallisiert:
Warum nicht gleich
zum Mount Everest gehen?
Wenn ich hinaufgehe
und den South Col erreiche,
dann bin ich schon
auf 8'000 m.ü.M.
Und wenn ich dann noch Kraft habe,
um zum Gipfel weiterzugehen,
wäre das
ein absoluter Knaller für mich.
Am Fusse des Everest geht die Arbeit
der Eisfalldoktoren derweil weiter.
Ang Nima sucht eine sichere Route.
Vorsichtig tastet er sich voran,
denn es besteht die Gefahr, in eine
verdeckte Gletscherspalte zu stürzen.
Ang Nima,
hast du keinen Weg gefunden?
Nein, nicht auf dieser Seite.
Es ist gefährlich.
Die andere Seite ist besser,
auch wenn sie länger ist.
Eine Leiter genügt dort.
Hier müssten wir 5 zusammenbinden.
Rund 55 bis 60 Leitern
und 3'500 m Seil
werden sie
in den nächsten Tagen verlegen.
Die gefährliche Arbeit
hinterlässt allerdings Spuren.
Selbst in der Nacht
schreckt Ang Nima immer wieder auf
und träumt vom Eisfall.
Im Basislager auf 5'340 m.ü.M.
treffen derweil Yaks und Träger
mit dem Material für
die verschiedenen Expeditionen ein.
Nicht weniger als 41 werden erwartet.
Die Sherpas von Kari Koblers
Expedition sind damit beschäftigt,
einen guten Lagerplatz
im Eis herauszuhacken.
Die Expeditionsteilnehmer nähern sich
Schritt für Schritt dem Basecamp
und tauchen in die Kultur
der Sherpas ein.
In Tengboche auf 3'860 m.ü.M
liegt das wichtigste
buddhistische Kloster des Tales.
2-mal wurde das Kloster
durch Katastrophen zerstört
und wieder aufgebaut.
Zeit für jeden Bergsteiger,
einen Moment innezuhalten.
Heizt ihr im Winter nicht mehr, weil
das Kloster einmal niederbrannte?
Ja.
Aber dann ist es sehr kalt
im Winter.
Zu kalt für mich.
- Ja.
Aber ihr lebt tief unten
und wir hoch oben.
Unser Blut ist sehr stark.
Ich bin ein junger Mann.
Ich muss jetzt rein,
danach können wir weitersprechen.
Hast du das gehört?
Weil das Kloster 1988 abbrannte,
heizen sie im Winter nicht mehr,
bei -20 °C.
Unglaublich!
Wenn man hier drin betet und dann
draussen diese Bergwelt sieht ...
Gut möglich, dass man da abhebt.
- Und die Kälte nicht mehr spürt.
Im Basislager
herrscht inzwischen Hochbetrieb.
Expeditionsleiter Kari Kobler
ist eingetroffen
und kontrolliert
die Aufbauarbeiten.
Zwischen den Eisbrocken platzieren
die Sherpas mehrere grosse Zelte,
wie hier das Materialzelt.
Und auch die gefährliche Arbeit
im Eisfall geht voran.
Mit mehr Kraft!
Ja, komm! Mit mehr Kraft!
Sie haben die gefährlichste Stelle
im Eisfall erreicht, den sog. Damm.
Fünf Leitern haben sie
zusammengebunden, um voranzukommen.
Ihr müsst sie nach dem
Zusammenbinden dort hinaufziehen.
Dahinter hat es ein grosses Loch.
Geh hoch und schau wie gross es ist!
Ist die Spalte sehr gross?
Das wissen wir,
wenn wir den Rand erreichen.
Geht es dort nicht weiter, müssen
wir woanders einen Weg suchen.
Bald werden Hunderte von Bergsteigern
über diese Leitern steigen,
die von Ang Nima
und seinem Team verlegt wurden.
Und ohne die
die meisten Everest-Aspiranten
nie eine Chance
auf den Gipfel hätten.
Noch ist der Gipfel auch für die
Schweizer Bergsteiger nur ein Traum.
Gemeinsam mit Norbu und Dorje kommen
sie dem Basislager immer näher.
Auf ihrem Weg stossen sie
auf einen Ort,
der ihnen die Gefahr ihres Traumes
vor Augen führt.
Leben und Tod
liegen am Everest nahe beieinander.
Davon zeugen in Dughla
diese steinernen Gedenkstätten.
Sie erinnern an all die Menschen,
die am Everest
ihr Leben gelassen haben.
Über 200 Tote hat der Everest
bis jetzt gefordert,
darunter viele westliche
Bergsteiger, aber auch Sherpas.
Und auch von dieser Expedition
wird einer nicht mehr zurückkehren.
Das mahnt einen
immer wieder zur Vorsicht,
weil man selber ein gleiches
Schicksal erleben könnte
oder eben nicht mehr
erleben könnte.
Gianni Goltz, der Tessiner stand
bereits auf sechs Achttausendern.
How do you feel?
- I'm fine.
Very fine.
It's really nice here.
Schön, sehr schön!
Nach sieben Tagen kommen die
Bergsteiger im Basecamp an.
Dieses ist mittlerweile zu
einer riesigen Zeltstadt angewachsen.
41 Expeditionen sind hier versammelt.
Das sind rund 1'000 Personen: Berg-
steiger, Sherpas und andere Helfer.
Kari Kobler allein
beschäftigt 15 Sherpas.
I'd just like to show you the team,
which will help us
to reach the biggest mountain
in the world.
Okay, I'll start here:
Dorje, 13-mal auf dem Everest.
Angelu, er spricht deutsch.
Mingma,
einer meiner ältesten Sherpas.
Mit ihm bestieg ich
schon letztes Jahr den Everest.
Dendi.
Wangchu, er hat schon viele Sachen
für uns gemacht.
Letztes Jahr
war er mit uns in Pakistan.
Er ist einer unserer Bekanntesten
zusammen mit Norbu.
Norbu gehört auch
zu unseren Top-Leuten.
Ich hoffe, sie helfen uns,
damit wir uns nachher
beglückwünschen können,
den Everest bestiegen zu haben.
Danke vielmals!
Wie hat Kari
sein Team zusammengestellt?
Es gibt einige wichtige Faktoren,
dass z.B. immer mindestens zwei
aus der gleichen Region sind.
Das ist eine uralte Auffassung
bei ihnen:
Sie wollen immer zu zweit sein,
sodass wenn einem etwas geschieht,
der andere ihm helfen kann.
Dazu müssen sie
aus der gleichen Region stammen.
Dann ist es auch wichtig,
dass starke Leute darunter sind.
Konditionell starke.
Sie müssen nicht
gut Englisch können,
sie fungieren
vor allem als Träger
und sind gewissermassen
der Motor des Sherpa-Teams.
Dann braucht es auch "Denker",
die das Ganze koordinieren.
Dann braucht es auch lustige Leute,
die Witze erzählen
und für eine gute Atmosphäre
in der Expeditionsgruppe sorgen.
In den nächsten Wochen werden
die Sherpas vom Basislager aus
weitere Lager einrichten:
Lager 1 auf 5'900 m.ü.M.
Lager 2 auf 6'400 m.ü.M.
Lager 3 auf 7'300 m.ü.M.
und Lager 4 auf 7'900 m.ü.M.
Sie werden diese Wege rauf- und
runtergehen und dabei Geld verdienen.
Der Lohn wird vorher
im Basislager ausgehandelt.
Kari Kobler bezahlt ein Grundsalär
von 2'000 $, plus Leistungslohn.
Je nachdem wie oft ein Sherpa
in ein Hochlager aufsteigt
und wie viel er trägt,
umso mehr Geld kann er verdienen.
Norbu, der junge Sirdar oder Chef der
Sherpas, übersetzt Karis Vorschläge.
Die Sherpas haben
ihre eigenen Vorstellungen.
Es folgen Lohnverhandlungen
wie auf dem Bazar.
Lasst uns mehr Grundlohn verlangen
statt mehr Bonus!
Andere Gruppen zahlen 2'200 $.
Lasst uns verhandeln!
Ja, wir sollten jetzt verhandeln.
Wie steht es mit den Zahlungen oben?
Wir sollten etwas mehr verlangen
für Lager 3.
Ins Camp 3 gehen wir ja nur einmal,
oder?
Und so wird um den Lohn
für jedes Hochlager gefeilscht.
Okay.
Ihr wollt 50.
Ich will 40 zahlen.
Also sagen wir 45.
Alle sollen zufrieden sein.
Ihr und ich.
Ich mag es nicht,
wenn ihr nicht zufrieden seid.
45 ist okay?
Dann Camp 3.
Wie viel für Camp 4?
Okay.
Mein letzter Preis für Camp 4:
120.
120 für Camp 4.
Das ist harte Arbeit.
Das weiss jeder. Camp 4 ist hart.
Seid ihr einverstanden?
Okay.
Er ist der härteste Mann.
Thank you!
Ein Sherpa
verdient für diese Expedition
zwischen 4'500 und 5'500 $,
je nach Leistung.
Ich erwarte von den Sherpas,
dass sie zusammenarbeiten.
Das ist wie ein autonomes Gebilde,
das ich über Jahre geformt habe.
Sie wissen, wie es funktionieren
muss und wie ich es mir vorstelle.
Und mittlerweile funktioniert es
absolut genial.
Sherpas wie Long Dorje verdienen
in den folgenden zwei Monaten
rund das doppelte Jahressalär
eines Lehrers in Kathmandu.
Dafür leisten sie aber fast Über-
menschliches und riskieren ihr Leben.
Wie ist Long Dorje
mit den Verhandlungen zufrieden?
Es war gut.
Die Diskussionen um den Bonus
waren auch gut.
Alle Kollegen sind zufrieden.
In den nächsten zwei Monaten
entsteht eine Schicksalsgemeinschaft
zwischen Sherpas
und Expeditionsteilnehmern.
Ihren Freiraum haben die Sherpas in
ihrem Küchenzelt mit eigenem Koch,
der nur nepalesische Gerichte kocht
wie hier Dhido, ein Gerstengericht.
Das Zelt ist Aufenthaltsraum:
Hier wird gegessen, diskutiert und
gelacht - ohne westliche Bergsteiger.
Die Expeditionsteilnehmer
haben ihr eigenes Zelt,
ihre eigene Küche
und angenehmen Luxus auf 5'340 m.ü.M.
Das Zelt ist geheizt.
Jeden Abend werden sie
mit einem 3-Gang-Menü überrascht,
gekocht und serviert
von der Sherpa-Küchenmannschaft.
Gekocht wird
nach dem Geschmack der Gäste.
Heute z.B. Pommes frites und Momos.
Guten Appetit miteinander!
Gemeinsam ist allen das Ziel:
der Mount Everest.
Wir respektieren den Everest
als unsere Mutter.
Gäbe es keinen Everest:
Können Sie sich vorstellen,
wie dann unser Leben wäre?
Der Berg ist ein göttliches Symbol.
Wir singen auch ein Lied:
"Ich kam zu dir, bitte liebe mich."
Wir summen stets das Mantra:
"Ohm Mani Padme Hum".
Am 17. April findet im Basislager
die buddhistische Puja statt.
Dieser Tag verheisst
im Kalender der Sherpas viel Glück.
Steigeisen und Pickel
werden gesegnet.
Ein bergsteigender Lama
führt durch die Zeremonie.
* Rhythmischer Singsang *
Opfergaben sollen die Götter
milde stimmen.
Während der rund
zweistündigen Zeremonie
ziehen die Sherpas bunte
Gebetsfahnen über das ganze Lager.
Der Wind soll die Gebete
in alle Himmelsrichtungen tragen
und Glück bringen.
Hast du Rupien?
Wait, wait!
How much do you have?
Dazu kommen irdische, finanzielle
Opfergaben, die der Lama bekommt.
Wer Glück für sich will,
muss auch etwas zahlen.
Zum Abschluss der Puja
werfen alle Mehl in die Luft.
* Johlen *
Ich fühlte mich in den letzten Tagen
nicht sehr gut.
Nun ist die Zeremonie
endlich vorbei.
Jetzt ist alles in Ordnung.
Ich bin glücklich.
Ich habe einen tiefen Glauben,
obschon ich gut ausgebildet bin
und in Kathmandu wohne
und nicht in einem Dorf.
Ich praktiziere meinen Glauben
auch in der Stadt.
Vor dem ersten Aufstieg sortieren die
Sherpas die riesige Menge Nahrung,
die sie in die einzelnen Hochlager
transportieren müssen.
All out! All out!
- First here, then there.
Es ist vor allem Nahrung,
die leicht verdaulich ist.
Jeder von euch bekommt einen Sack
und später nehmen wir noch einen.
Die Expeditionsteilnehmer
bekommen solche Säcke,
in die sie ihr eigenes Material
packen und den Sherpas mitgeben.
Das ist nicht genug.
Es sollten 12 kg sein für jeden.
Wir geben hier
einen zweiten Sack dazu.
Ich wiege alles,
um das genaue Gewicht zu kennen.
Erstes Ziel ist das Lager 1
auf 5'900 m.ü.M.
Der Weg führt vom Basislager
durch den Eisfall.
Bereits um 3 Uhr morgens
machen sich die Sherpas auf den Weg.
Das ist das Leben der Sherpas.
Was kann man da machen?
Sherpas aller Expeditionen
wollen heute das Material für ihre
Teilnehmer ins Lager 1 hinaufbringen.
Alle folgen der Route, welche
die Eisfalldoktoren gelegt haben.
Bereits morgens um 5 Uhr kommt es
zu ersten Staus im Eisfall.
Der Aufstieg ist schwierig.
Auch für erfahrene Sherpas wie Norbu
ist es nicht leicht,
auf über 5'500 m.ü.M. Lasten von
20 kg oder mehr zu transportieren.
Etwas später starten
die Expeditionsteilnehmer.
Obwohl sie alle sehr erfahren sind
und teilweise als Bergführer
in der Schweiz arbeiten,
sind die Leitern
auch für sie eine Mutprobe.
Ein Fehltritt
könnte fatale Folgen haben.
Langsam und konzentriert bewegen sie
sich in der ungewohnten Höhe.
Nach 3 Std. erreichen die Sherpas
Lager 1 auf 5'900 m.ü.M.
Sie stellen die Zelte
für ihre Kunden auf,
die eine Nacht hier verbringen
werden, um sich zu akklimatisieren.
Fixiere die Heringe
auf allen vier Seiten!
Nachdem die Sherpas
die Zelte verankert
und das Material deponiert haben,
steigen sie wieder ab ins Basis-
lager, um weiteres Gepäck zu holen.
Auch Ang Nima und seine
Eisfalldoktoren sind gefordert.
Sie müssen
neue Leitern und Seile legen,
da sich die Eismassen
ständig bewegen
und Hunderte von Leuten
zur gleichen Zeit unterwegs sind.
(Ang Nima)
Diese verrückten Gletscherspalten!
Heute haben wir
einen neuen Weg ausprobiert.
Durch die Wärme lösen sich Lawinen,
die in den Eisfall donnern.
Die Sherpas arbeiten die nächsten
6 Wochen praktisch ohne Unterbruch.
Kaum zurück im Basislager, packen sie
neues Material für das Lager 2.
Teilen wir die Sachen auf!
Schauen wir zuerst
das Material der Members an!
Dann die Eisschrauben,
die Seile und die Felshaken.
Ich liebe es zwar, in den Bergen
und auf dem Gipfel zu sein,
aber der Anfang einer Expedition
gefällt mir nicht.
Dann ist der Job sehr hart,
mit all den Lasten
und dem Aufbau der Zelte.
Das ist alles sehr, sehr hart.
Das ist der strenge Teil
dieses Jobs.
Am nächsten Tag steigen die Sherpas
aller Expeditionen zum ersten Mal
zum Camp 2 auf.
Norbu ist bereits eingetroffen,
um einen guten Platz
für die Expedition von Kari Kobler
zu reservieren.
Hier entsteht ein vorgeschobenes
Basislager mit allem Komfort.
Wie geht's?
Comme ci, comme ça.
Stellt drei Zelte da drüben hin!
Vier bis fünf Teilnehmer
werden heute hier oben schlafen.
Kommt Jungs,
lasst uns den Platz vorbereiten!
Wir müssen arbeiten,
keine Zeit zum Ausruhen.
Sherpa Dendi bringt 20 l Kerosen,
das zum Kochen gebraucht wird.
Die anderen Sherpas bauen
ein komplettes Küchenzelt auf.
Der Koch wird in den nächsten Wochen
hier oben bleiben.
Inzwischen trifft auch Long Dorje
mit neuem Gepäck ein.
Fünf Schlafzelte sowie ein geräumiges
Esszelt mit Tischen und Stühlen
errichten die Sherpas
für die Expeditionsmitglieder.
Long Dorje kämpft
mit der noch ungewohnten Höhe.
Ich habe fürchterliches Kopfweh.
Wenn ich mich bücke,
habe ich das Gefühl zu fallen.
Die Küchenmannschaft sucht inzwi-
schen im Gletscher frisches Eis,
um Wasser abzukochen.
Dabei stossen sie auf einen grausigen
Fund direkt neben ihrem Lagerplatz.
Der Gletscher hat Leichenteile
eines Bergsteigers,
der vor Jahren in eine Gletscher-
spalte gefallen ist, freigegeben.
Das ist nur eine von vielen Leichen,
die am Everest verschollen sind.
Viele der verunglückten Bergsteiger
werden nie mehr gefunden.
Der Tod ist Teil
jeder Everest-Besteigung.
Für die Sherpas
geht die Arbeit weiter.
Um bei Kräften zu bleiben, gehört
eine Pause mit viel Flüssigkeit dazu.
3 bis 5 l pro Tag
sollten getrunken werden,
da der Körper auf dieser Höhe
sehr viel Flüssigkeit verliert.
Dann bricht Long Dorje wieder auf,
um im über 1'000 m tiefer gelegene
Basecamp neue Lasten zu holen.
Fünf Tage lang werden die Sherpas
nun immer wieder Material
vom Basislager ins Camp 2
hinauftransportieren.
Norbu bleibt im Lager 2
und organisiert die Transporte.
Ein Solarladegerät, 2 grosse Matten
und ein Medizinkoffer.
Währenddessen befinden sich die
Schweizer Bergsteiger im Eisfall,
gemeinsam mit vielen Teilnehmern
anderer Expeditionen.
Mit leichtem Gepäck
sind sie zum Camp 2 unterwegs,
wo einige eine weitere Nacht zur
Akklimatisation verbringen werden.
Absteigende Sherpas
kommen ihnen entgegen.
Unerfahrene Everest-Aspiranten
versperren den Weg.
Wait, wait!
Was alle befürchtet haben, passiert:
Es kommt zum Stau
auf über 5'800 m.ü.M.
Long Dorje ist bereits wieder
im Basislager.
Sherpas leiden in der Höhe
wie jeder westliche Bergsteiger auch.
Sie dürfen sich aber
nichts anmerken lassen
und lächeln immer freundlich
wie Long Dorje.
Auch wenn es wehtut,
muss man immer Stehvermögen zeigen.
Dazu sind wir gezwungen.
Es gibt Sherpas,
die lassen alle Last zurück,
wenn sie sich nicht wohlfühlen.
Einige kehren sogar um,
ohne etwas zu tun,
aber die bekommen später Probleme.
Wenn der Sirdar
Schwäche in uns sieht,
wird er sagen,
wir würden simulieren.
Dann bekommen wir
keine Anstellung mehr.
Die ersten Expeditionsmitglieder kom-
men im fertig aufgebauten Lager 2 an.
Die Sherpas heissen sie freundlich
mit heissem Tee willkommen.
Im Materialzelt macht Norbu Inventar.
8 Stück für dich.
Wie viele Gaskartuschen?
- 46 Stück.
Mammutseile, 11 mm. Wie viele?
U.a. stehen 50 Flaschen
mit lebenswichtigem Sauerstoff
für den Transport
in weitere Hochlager bereit.
Ich muss die Karabiner kontrollie-
ren, ich dachte, wir hätten genug.
Ich habe fünf.
Wie viele sind auf der Liste?
Lass uns die Zelte aufräumen
und das Gepäck der Mitglieder
in einem Zelt abstellen.
Dann ist unsere Arbeit
für heute zu Ende.
Jetzt wäre alles bereit, um
die weiteren Hochlager einzurichten.
Die Expeditionsmitglieder Patrick
Z'Brun und Meinrad Bitel
sind wieder ins Basislager
abgestiegen.
Sie übernachten
nicht wie die anderen im Lager 2.
Die beiden sind beeindruckt,
was die Sherpas leisten.
Ein Sherpa startete frühmorgens vom
Basislager mit rund 60 kg Kerosen.
Er ging ins Lager 2
und kam danach wieder zurück.
Das ist unglaublich!
60 kg von 5'300 m.ü.M.
auf 6'400 m.ü.M. an einem Tag
und dann wieder zurück.
Das ist unvorstellbar.
Das würden wir keine Stunde
geradeaus tragen können.
Dann folgt ein Wettereinbruch.
Er hindert die Sherpas daran,
weiterzuarbeiten.
Sie sitzen im Basislager fest.
Mit jedem Tag warten,
steigt der Druck.
Wenn das Wetter wieder schön wird,
müssen sie doppelt zupacken.
Es kann sein, dass wir
am 6. starten können oder am 4.
Aber dann ist
sehr viel Sherpa-Kraft nötig.
Harte Arbeit,
um schnell nach oben zu kommen,
harte Arbeit von jedem Sherpa.
Wenn das passiert,
brauche ich eure Power.
Manchmal braucht ihr mein Geld,
manchmal brauche ich eure Power.
Sherpas sind wirklich
viel stärker als Westler.
Wir sind von Geburt an
an Berge gewöhnt.
Das ist vererbt.
Aber noch etwas treibt die Leute an:
das Geld.
Patrick Z'Brun hat sich
während der Wartezeit
in die Geschichte der Sherpas
eingelesen.
Das ist ein Buch
über die Geschichte der Sherpas
von Judy und Tashi Tenzing.
Sie erzählen, wie das Volk
der Sherpas in die Berge kam,
als Träger und Bergführer.
Am Schluss gibt es eine Liste
mit allen Sherpas,
die auf dem Everest waren.
Da entdeckte ich dich, Lambu,
oder Long Dorje aus Thamo.
Wusstest du, dass es eine Liste
gibt, wo du draufstehst?
Nein.
Was ist heute der Rekord?
Der Erste ist Appa Sherpa, 17-mal.
Der Zweite ist Thong Nima.
(Patrick) Und dann Dorje?
Ja, er war 13-mal oben.
Patrick:
Wie oft warst du denn oben?
Ich war noch nie oben.
Ich war schon auf 8'600,
8'700 m.ü.M
und bin immer wieder
mit den Teilnehmern umgekehrt.
Wenn ich es dieses Mal schaffe,
schreibe ich einen Artikel,
denn ich begann als Küchenjunge,
wurde Sirdar
und habe etliche 8'000er bestiegen.
(Patrick) Wie alt bist du jetzt?
- 29.
Und du, 42?
- Ja.
Wir haben wirklich Glück, Sherpas
wie euch beide bei uns zu haben.
It's our pleasure.
- Danke.
Ich habe ein sehr gutes Gefühl
mit euch zweien.
Wir sind auch sehr glücklich, so
starke Mitglieder wie euch zu haben.
Oh, come on.
* Erhabene Musik *
Endlich können die Arbeiten
am Everest weitergehen.
15 starke Sherpas aus den
verschiedenen Expeditionsteams
machen sich auf den Weg.
In den nächsten Tagen werden sie
in mehreren Etappen
vom Camp 2 auf 6'400 m.ü.M.
bis auf den Gipfel auf 8'850 m.ü.M
Seile fixieren.
Alle Sherpas der grossen Expeditionen
arbeiten hier zusammen.
Es ist eine überaus gefährliche
Arbeit, die sie hier verrichten
im über 45 Grad steilen,
vereisten Gelände der Lhotseflanke.
Es sind viele junge Sherpas dabei,
die technisch versiert sind
und jeden Handgriff beherrschen.
Geh ein bisschen zur Seite!
Wir haben eine Spalte gesehen.
Die wollen wir vermeiden.
Die Seilmannschaft
verlegt Meter um Meter Seil,
an denen sich in ein paar Tagen
hunderte von zahlenden Gästen
hochziehen und sichern werden.
Gegen Abend ist die Mannschaft,
die die Seile fixiert hat, zurück.
Eine weitere Gruppe von Sherpas
macht sich bereit
für die nächste Etappe
auf 7'900 m.ü.M.
Die Sherpas aller Expeditionen
organisieren sich untereinander
und teilen die Gruppen ein.
Es sind 16 Leute.
Lasst es uns in zwei Gruppen machen!
Eine muss den Gipfel einrichten,
davon zwei von Kari Kobler.
Von Kobler und Partner
ist Long Dorje dabei.
Auch die Schweizer Expeditionsteil-
nehmer rückten ins Lager 2 nach.
Die Küchenmannschaft
ist damit beschäftigt,
für sich und die Schweizer Gäste
das Abendessen zuzubereiten.
Flüssigkeit ist die Grundlage
für eine gute Akklimatisation.
Die Expeditionsteilnehmer
lassen es sich gut gehen
und erholen sich, bevor sie
erstmals ins Lager 3 aufsteigen.
Dieses muss von Norbu und seinen Leu-
ten aber zuerst aufgestellt werden.
Vom Basislager aus
koordiniert Kari Kobler die Arbeiten
und schaut,
dass der Zeitplan eingehalten wird.
Camp 2 von Charly antworten.
Perfekt.
Wie geht es mit Lager 3?
Sie sind auf halbem Weg ins Lager 3
und fixieren die Seile.
Heute Abend werden sie
Lager 3 erreichen
und morgen Früh
brechen auch wir auf.
Okay.
Wer geht morgen ins Lager 3?
Ich, Wangchu,
insgesamt vier Sherpas.
Okay, dann schicken wir auch
die Teilnehmer.
Sie sollen dort übernachten.
Nein,
übermorgen können sie ins Lager 3.
Keine gute Idee.
Wenn ihr morgen früh die Zelte
aufbaut, sollte es gehen.
Okay, Charly, wir schauen morgen.
Versucht es!
Ohne Sherpas läuft nichts.
Wir müssen alles machen.
Wir sind wie Leitern
für die Teilnehmer.
Wir bauen die Sprossen.
Sie erreichen den Gipfel
nur über diese Sprossen.
Norbu transportiert morgen mit
seinem Team Material ins Lager 3,
während Dorje weitere Seile
bis auf 7'900 m.ü.M. verlegt.
Dies sei einer der härtesten Tage,
meint Norbu.
Mühsam kämpfen sich die Sherpas
an den gestern verlegten Seilen
die 45 Grad steile
Lhotseflanke hoch.
Im Gepäck Zelte, Matten, Kocher
und Schaufeln für Lager 3.
Die Anstrengung in der immer dünner
werdenden Luft ist gross.
Selbst die Sherpas
kommen an ihre Grenzen.
Einige Sherpas hören nach nur einer
Expedition mit dieser Arbeit auf.
Sie ist physisch und mental
sehr anstrengend.
Wenn man jung ist,
hat man diese Kraft,
aber diesen Job
kann man nicht ewig machen.
Nach 3 Std. haben sie
auf 7'300 m.ü.M.
den Platz für Lager 3 erreicht.
Zwischen Gletscherspalten
bauen sie die Zelte auf.
Lasst uns hier beginnen!
Wir können den Schnee
auf dieser Seite aufhacken.
Es ist ein exponierter Platz.
Die Sherpas müssen für jedes Zelt
das Eis aufhacken
und den Boden ebnen.
Auch hier fällt das Gelände
bis zu 45 Grad steil ab.
Inzwischen befinden sich Long Dorje
und sein Team auf über 7'500 m.ü.M.
Hallo, grosser Held! Was gibt's?
Der Held hat es schwer.
Wir müssen das Seil hier
mit einem Firnanker fixieren.
Wir brauchen noch etliche
auf dieser Seite.
Long Dorje erinnert sich nicht gerne
an diese Stelle.
Wechselt das Wetter
und fällt Schnee,
können die steilen Wände
des Everest zur Todesfalle werden.
Vor Jahren geriet Dorje hier
in eine Lawine
und überlebte nur mit viel Glück.
Ich habe viele Unfälle gesehen.
Freunde von mir
sind am Everest gestorben,
einige sogar vor meinen Augen.
Leute wurden
von Lawinen mitgerissen,
fielen in Gletscherspalten,
viele solcher Unfälle.
Wie fühlst du dich,
wenn du daran denkst?
Sehr traurig.
Ich möchte weinen.
Ein Freund von mir
starb hier vor meinen Augen.
Auch einige, die im gleichen Zelt
schliefen, hat es erwischt.
Wenn ich daran denke,
möchte ich niemals hier rauf
und nie mehr
diesen Job verrichten.
Aber ich bin gezwungen zu arbeiten.
Doch es schmerzt,
wenn man daran denkt.
Weit weg in Dorjes Heimatdorf Thamo
geht das Leben seinen gewohnten Gang.
Dorjes Ehefrau Pasang Tiki hackt
die Kartoffelstauden auf dem Feld.
Sie hat kein Telefon
und weiss nicht,
wie es ihrem Mann am Everest geht.
Ich kümmere mich um die Kartoffeln,
giesse die Knoblauchstauden,
jäte Unkraut, putze den Garten.
Lauter solche Arbeiten,
wenn Dorje weg ist in den Bergen.
Das ist meine Arbeit im Moment.
Jeden Passanten fragt sie, ob er
Neuigkeiten vom Everest bringe.
Wenn nicht, bittet sie ihn,
sie doch sofort zu informieren,
wenn er etwas hört.
Ich warte auf ihn, dass er
zurückkommt und alles gut geht.
Ich bin so glücklich
nach seiner Rückkehr.
Wenn das Wetter schlecht wird, gehen
mir viele Dinge durch den Kopf.
Um sich zu beruhigen, praktiziert
Pasang Tiki jahrhundertealte Rituale.
Sie präpariert Reisbier,
das kalt gestellt wird,
bis Long Dorje vom Berg zurückkommt
und das erste Glas trinkt.
Ihr Glaube gibt ihr Kraft.
Wir gehen zum "Kerak"-Kloster
in der Nähe, um zu beten,
einige Tage, bevor sie
den Gipfel in Angriff nehmen.
Das letzte Mal brachte ich Reisbier
ins Kloster.
Dann beten wir erneut im Kloster
und führen
das "Kangsur"-Ritual durch.
Long Dorje, Norbu sowie Hunderte
von Sherpas anderer Expeditionen
transportieren nun die
lebenswichtigen Sauerstoffflaschen
für den Gipfeltag ins Lager 4
auf 7'900 m.ü.M.
Für viele dieser Sherpas
ist es das wichtigste Einkommen,
mit dem sie ihre Familien ernähren
können - v.a. für die älteren.
Dieser Sherpa einer anderen Expedi-
tion trägt zwölf Sauerstoffflaschen,
also etwa 42 kg
auf 7'900 m.ü.M. hoch.
Woher er die Kraft nimmt,
kann niemand nachvollziehen.
Die Schweizer Bergsteiger
geniessen den Luxus
des fertig eingerichteten Lagers 3.
Freust du dich auf den Berg?
Ich fühle mich grossartig,
weil die Sherpas
grossartige Arbeit geleistet haben.
Die Fixseile
und alles andere hier war bereit.
Man muss nur dem Seil folgen
und ins Zelt sitzen.
Bist du zufrieden
mit dem Sherpa-Team?
Sie sind hervorragend.
Und Gianni, der ohne Sauerstoff
auf den Gipfel will?
Du hast
schon sechs Achttausender bestiegen?
Was ist der Unterschied zum Everest?
Das ist der höchste.
Und der Verkehr?
Ja, viel Verkehr.
Bei anderen Expeditionen trifft man
20 Leute, hier 200 bis 300.
Ist es hart?
Man muss sich daran gewöhnen,
dann geht es.
Es macht dir nichts aus?
Nein, es ist normal.
Im Pulk und in der Kälte kämpfen sich
ihre Sherpas weiter voran.
Heute sind es zu viele Leute.
Man kann die Bergsteiger
fast nicht überholen.
Einige laufen schnell,
andere langsam. Es stockt.
Es wäre einfacher, wenn alle
gleich schnell marschieren würden,
aber so ist das Laufen
völlig desorganisiert.
Nach 5 Std. erreichen
die ersten Sherpas von Kari Kobler
das Lager 4 auf 7'900 m.ü.M.
Sie besetzen einen Lagerplatz,
deponieren ihre Last,
darunter 50 Sauerstoffflaschen.
Diese versehen sie vorsichtshalber
mit einem Schloss.
In der Todeszone
traut man niemandem mehr.
Auch Long Dorje hat es endlich
geschafft.
Im Pulk musste er immer wieder warten
und hat viel Energie verbraucht.
Ich bin heute zum ersten Mal
auf dem Südsattel.
Einige sind schon wieder
zurückgegangen.
Ich deponiere hier die Sauerstoff-
flaschen und andere Sachen.
Drei Freunde sind noch hinter mir.
Es ist etwas windig,
Nebel kommt auf.
Aber es ist immer noch okay, nicht
gefährlich, alles ist noch gut.
So schnell wie möglich machen sie
sich wieder auf den Abstieg.
Ihre Arbeit ist nun getan.
Alles ist eingerichtet
und bereit für den Gipfelsturm.
Die Natur am Everest ist fantastisch,
aber auch gefährlich.
Norbu und die anderen Sherpas
sind glücklich,
nach all den harten Tagen wieder
heil im Basislager einzutreffen.
Wäre ich in Kathmandu, würde mir
jetzt meine Freundin helfen,
mein Gepäck im Zelt zu verstauen.
Aber hier bin ich alleine.
Ich muss alles selber erledigen.
Das ist wie eine Ein-Mann-Armee.
Die Kleider müssen gewaschen werden.
Stinken sie?
Keine Frage.
Meine Füsse besonders.
Selbst Fische würden sterben,
wenn ich sie ins Wasser hielte.
Giftiger Abfall!
Alle Arbeit ist getan.
Alle Arbeit der Sherpas.
Jetzt müssen wir nur noch die
Teilnehmer auf den Gipfel bringen.
Wir warten auf diesen Tag.
Für den Gipfelsturm
bekommt jetzt jeder Bergsteiger
seinen persönlichen Sherpa
zugeteilt,
der ihn während des Aufstiegs
zum Gipfel begleitet.
Patrick is with Lombo Dujee.
Wo ist Patrick?
- Ich bin hier.- Ah, sorry.
Dann Pitch mit Norbu.
Richard mit Wangchu.
Und Gianni mit Mingma.
Ich habe versucht,
eine gute Mischung zu erhalten.
Es gibt verschiedene Kriterien:
Stärke, Sprachkenntnisse ...
Auf jeden Fall so,
dass es eine gute Mischung gibt.
Gianni und Richard werden
vermutlich miteinander gehen.
Wangchu spricht gut englisch
und ist technisch super stark.
Mingma ist auch
eine kleine Maschine.
It the member
is not strong enough to go alone ...
Norbu betont noch einmal, dass die
Teilnehmer die Hilfe der Sherpas
auch beim Abstieg
in Anspruch nehmen können.
Dieses Mal
sind alle Bergsteiger stark.
Aber oft ist dies nicht der Fall.
Mit einem schwachen Teilnehmer
musst du bei schlechtem Wetter
immer den Karabiner einhängen
und du musst ihm Wasser geben.
Immer musst du
die Handschuhe ausziehen.
Das Risiko zu verunglücken
ist viel grösser,
wenn der Teilnehmer schwach ist.
Manchmal macht es
den Sherpa richtig aggressiv,
wenn er mit einem Schwachen
unterwegs ist.
Aber wir dürfen es nicht zeigen,
wir sind dafür bezahlt.
Im Basecamp können wir mit unseren
Freunden dann darüber reden,
aber nicht mit den Teilnehmern.
Da haben wir genug Zeit ...
Dann instruiert Kari Kobler
seine Teilnehmer
über den Umgang mit Sauerstoff.
Denn die Luft auf 8'000 m.ü.M.
ist so dünn,
dass der Mensch durch
Sauerstoffmangel höhenkrank werden
und daran sterben kann.
Wenn ihr oben keinen Sauerstoff
mehr habt, wird es gefährlich.
Das ist einer der Gründe ...
Gianni will trotzdem
ohne Sauerstoff aufsteigen.
Aus bergsteigerischem Ehrgeiz,
will er alle Achttausender
ohne Sauerstoff bezwingen.
Der Sherpa ist auch
aus Kontrollgründen dabei.
Er würde merken,
wenn ihr höhenkrank würdet.
Dann ist euer Gehirn ausgeschaltet.
Das passiert regelmässig.
Es kann nicht sein,
dass die Sherpas das Leben
für jemanden riskieren,
der zu viel riskiert.
Frühmorgens rezitiert Sherpa Norbu im
Zelt die Mantras für Guru Rinpoche.
Der grosse Tantra-Meister
soll ihm beim Gipfelsturm helfen
und ihn beschützen.
Um 4 Uhr machen sich die Schweizer
Expeditionsteilnehmer auf den Weg
in den Khumbu-Eisfall,
begleitet von Sherpa-Kameraleuten.
Auch Gianni und Richard
montieren ihre Steigeisen.
Time to get ready.
Aber heute langsam, ganz langsam.
Ihr wollt den Everest
ohne Sauerstoff besteigen?
Ja.
Wir versuchen es ohne Sauerstoff.
- Ja.
Mal sehen, wie weit wir kommen,
vielleicht auf den Gipfel.
Es wird sehr schwierig,
aber wir versuchen es.
Ich hoffe, auf den Gipfel zu kommen
- ohne Sauerstoff.
Der wahre Everest
ist der Everest ohne Sauerstoff.
Okay.
- Okay.
Good luck!
- Thank you very much. Good luck!
Gianni und Richard
verabschieden sich.
Gianni weiss nicht,
dass es ein endgültiger Abschied ist.
Sein Traum alle Achttausender
ohne Sauerstoff zu bezwingen,
wird tragisch enden.
Einmal mehr gehen jetzt alle Sherpas
und Bergsteiger durch den Eisfall.
Es ist Mitte Mai.
Die meisten Everest-Besteigungen
finden in dieser Zeit statt,
kurz vor dem Hereinbrechen
des Monsuns.
Dann sind Wind und Wetter günstig.
Frühmorgens am zweiten Tag
zieht die Schweizer Expedition los
Richtung Lhotseflanke.
Mit dabei: die speziell ausgebildeten
Kamera-Sherpas,
welche diese einzigartigen Bilder
liefern und in den folgenden Tagen
die Geschichte der Expedition bis
auf den Gipfel dokumentieren werden.
Winde mit über 60 km/h peitschen
über die eisige Lhotseflanke.
In Lager 3 auf 7'300 m.ü.M.
ist für die westlichen Bergsteiger
wie immer alles bereit:
Zelt, Matten, Gaskocher, Schlafsack.
Die Sherpas
bleiben heute im Lager 2
und kontrollieren ein letztes Mal
die neuen Sauerstoffmasken.
Der Sauerstoff
ist jetzt auf Level 25.
Die Nadel geht zurück, wenn
der Sauerstoff aufgebraucht wird.
Sie geht auf 0.
Wenn der Zähler
zwischen 0 und 5 ist,
müsst ihr die Flasche auswechseln.
Habt ihr das verstanden?
Das ist 0.
Passt bitte auf!
Die Sherpas sind
für den Sauerstoff verantwortlich.
Wir haben alle Masken kontrolliert.
Denn manchmal stösst man
auf eine defekte Maske,
wenn man sie
auf dem Südsattel braucht.
Darum kontrollieren wir sie
hier unten schon genau.
Im Lager 3
hat Expeditionsleiter Kari Kobler
eben die neusten Wetterdaten
aus der Schweiz erhalten.
Jetzt gibt er sie per Funk an Norbu
im Lager 2 weiter.
Norbu, du kannst jetzt
die Wettervorhersage
dem Seilteam weiterleiten.
Bis Mitternacht gibt es noch Wind.
Gegen morgen Mittag
wird es windstill.
Dafür nimmt die Bewölkung zu.
Aber in der Nacht sollte es wieder
sehr schön sein.
Am 21., um Mittag,
könnte es etwas Schneefall geben.
Leichte Niederschläge,
aber kein Wind bis am 22.
Okay,
ich leite die Informationen weiter.
6 Uhr am nächsten Tag.
Die Sherpas steigen heute direkt
vom Lager 2 ins Lager 4 hoch.
Aber sie haben sich verschlafen.
Es ist schon 6 Uhr!
Wir wollten eigentlich
um 5 Uhr losziehen.
Hätte ich meine Freunde
nicht geweckt,
würden sie noch immer pennen.
Sie schliefen tief, weiss nicht,
warum. Es war schön warm.
Verspätet laufen sie los,
was Folgen haben wird.
Im Lager 3 brechen inzwischen die
Teilnehmer Richtung Südsattel auf.
Als die Sherpas schliesslich
im Lager 3 eintreffen,
erwartet sie
eine böse Überraschung:
Einige Bergsteiger liessen
Schlafsäcke und Matten liegen,
da nicht klar abgesprochen war,
wer die Last mitnehmen soll.
Nun müssen die Sherpas
zusätzliches Gewicht schleppen.
Wie viele Sauerstoffflaschen
hast du?
Okay, wir nehmen alle 3.
Ich eine und Gelu eine.
Die dritte geben wir Ang Temba,
Lakpa oder Nima Thundu.
Keiner ist begeistert
von 7'300 m.ü.M. auf 7'900 m.ü.M
noch mehr Material mitzutragen.
Norbu ist wütend:
Vergeudet nicht eure Zeit!
Packt das Gepäck
und lasst uns hochklettern!
Trödle nicht rum!
Pack dein Gepäck, das ist dein Job!
Und morgen verlangen wir mehr Geld.
Wir müssen es mitnehmen.
Es bringt nichts, wenn wir streiten.
Wären wir rechtzeitig gegangen, hät-
ten wir die Teilnehmer getroffen
und das anders verteilen können.
Aber ihr habt ja verpennt.
Sonst hätten wir das
mit Kari besprechen können.
Aber der ist auch schon weg.
- Sie sind alle weg.
Statt wie vorgesehen 12 kg,
schleppt jeder Sherpa
jetzt mind. 26 kg.
So auch Dorje und Norbu,
welche als Letzte lossteigen.
Trotzdem holen die ersten Sherpas
ihre Bergsteiger am Genfer Sporn
auf 7'600 m.ü.M. ein.
Gianni ruht sich aus.
Er will seine Kräfte schonen.
Bist du okay?
- Ja, okay.
Ich brauche die Energie für morgen.
Gute Leute!
Weiter unten in der Masse
kämpfen Norbu und die anderen Sherpas
in der dünnen Luft.
Die Sonne brennt,
die Temperatur liegt bei 0 °C.
Diese Last ist zu schwer.
- Jedermanns Last ist schwer heute.
Die persönlichen Sachen
der Teilnehmer.
Gegen 13 Uhr erreichen
die Schweizer Bergsteiger
den Südsattel auf 7'900 m.ü.M.
Das letzte Hochlager vor dem Gipfel.
Die Anspannung ist gross.
Norbu hingegen befindet sich
immer noch im Aufstieg.
Mit ihrem schweren Gepäck
kommen die Sherpas nur mühsam voran.
Es ist ein schwieriger Job heute.
Denn jeder von uns
trägt 25 bis 26 kg.
Die Teilnehmer
haben alles zurückgelassen.
Sie tragen nur ihre Unterhosen,
den Daunenanzug
und einen kleinen Rucksack.
So schweres Gepäck
zwischen 7'300 m.ü.M. und
7'900 m.ü.M. zu tragen, ist hart.
Einige brauchen
zusätzlich Sauerstoff,
aber es ist trotzdem
ein sehr schwieriger Job.
Doch man vergisst alles, wenn man
wieder zurück im Basecamp ist.
Wir dürfen uns aber
all diese Schwierigkeiten
nicht anmerken lassen.
Wir müssen immer
eine fröhliche Miene aufsetzen.
Da kann man nichts machen.
Das ist die Natur dieses Jobs.
Nach über 8 std. Aufstieg
wird Norbu von Expeditionsleiter
Kari Kobler im Lager 4 begrüsst.
Bist du müde?
- Nein, nicht so sehr.
Sehr gut.
Okay.
Das ganze Gepäck ist jetzt oben.
- Gelu Sherpa beklagte sich am Funk.
Dann sagte ich ihm:
"Wenn du am Funk sprechen kannst,
kannst du auch klettern."
Die westlichen Bergsteiger
entspannen sich und probieren,
wieder zu Kräften zu kommen.
Speziell Gianni, der ohne Sauerstoff
auf den Gipfel will,
müsste sich hier gut regenerieren.
Aber er wirkt müde.
Es war heute lang und hart.
Wir begannen nicht so früh.
Aber es waren viele Leute.
Wir mussten oft warten.
Langsam, langsam.
Long Dorje trifft
als einer der Letzten ein.
Ich habe mir
einen Sonnenbrand geholt.
Ich bin in der Mittagssonne
stecken geblieben.
Und so komme ich erst jetzt.
Norbu und sein Sherpa-Team
teilen nun
die 50 Sauerstoffflaschen
untereinander auf.
Ein Teilnehmer
bekommt vier Sauerstoffflaschen.
Eine kann er schon im Lager 3
brauchen oder auf dem Südsattel.
Drei bleiben dann noch übrig.
Sie werden eine
beim Aufstieg benützen
und wir tragen die anderen zwei.
Eine ist Reserve,
eine weitere benützen wir.
Insgesamt tragen wir vier Flaschen.
Wir starten um 22 Uhr.
Alles ist jetzt bereit. Nun können
wir uns 3-4 Std. ausruhen.
Die Jungs werden etwas essen und
trinken und danach etwas schlafen.
Mitten in der Nacht
geht es dann los.
Was schmierst du dir da ins Gesicht?
- Es brennt so!
Der abgekochte Tee
wird zum Gipfel mitgenommen.
Heute war es wirklich schwierig.
Willst du nicht aufhören?
Ja, schon.
Aber dann ist da auch die Vorfreude
auf den Gipfel.
Das ist mein erstes Mal.
Ich habe Kopfweh.
Diesen Job kann man nicht aufgeben.
Das Geld ...
Es wird eine kurze Ruhepause.
Zu dritt oder zu viert in einem Zelt
versuchen sie, sich zu entspannen.
Long Dorje nimmt Sauerstoff,
um sich besser zu erholen.
Jetzt ist es 20 Uhr.
Nur noch 2 Std.
Ich will mich etwas ausruhen.
20. Mai 2008.
Vollmond - 22 Uhr.
Norbu ist der Erste,
der aus dem Zelt kriecht.
Charly, alles okay?
Guten Morgen!
Tashi dele Dorje, guten Morgen!
Alles okay?
- Alles okay?
Die Sherpas kontrollieren ein
letztes Mal die Sauerstoffflaschen.
Level 2?
- Nein, Level 3 ist gut.
Auch die Sherpas
benützen von nun an Sauerstoffgeräte.
Warte!
Das musst du besser anziehen hier!
Zuerst hier unten.
Und dann musst du hier oben ziehen.
Wie ist meine Sauerstoffflasche
eingestellt?
Auf 1. Das ist gut.
Also mein Freund:
Viel Glück!
Und dann marschieren sie los,
im Licht ihrer Stirnlampen.
Die ganze Nacht hindurch.
Über 100 Alpinisten wollen in dieser
Nacht auf den Gipfel aller Gipfel.
Gianni ist bereits eine Stunde
vor den anderen aufgebrochen,
da er ohne Sauerstoff
langsamer läuft.
Auf etwa 8'400 m.ü.M.,
unter dem Balcony, überholen sie ihn.
Hier wechseln die anderen Teilnehmer
ihre ersten Sauerstoffflaschen.
Um 5 Uhr morgens
erreichen sie den Südgipfel.
Die Verhältnisse sind gut,
aber jeder Schritt schmerzt.
Die Sherpas sichern ihre Gäste,
wenn die Kraft
auf 8'700 m.ü.M. ausgeht.
Auch Long Dorje
leidet in dieser Höhe.
Tief unten liegt das Hochland
von Tibet.
Nur gerade 90 Höhenmeter unter dem
Gipfel liegt das letzte Steilstück,
der Hillary Step.
Benannt nach dem Erstbegeher
des Everest: Sir Edmund Hillary.
Und dann ist es geschafft.
Kurz vor 9 Uhr stehen die Expedi-
tionsteilnehmer von Kari Kobler
auf dem höchsten Gipfel der Welt:
dem Mount Everest, auf 8'850 m.ü.M.
Danke, Jesus!
Danke, mein bester Freund, Patrick!
Wir haben es geschafft!
We did it.
Das Schweizer Bergsteigerteam ist
vor ihren Sherpas auf dem Gipfel,
die noch im Stau stecken.
The top of the world, hä!
Auch für die Sherpas hat es geklappt.
Norbu steht zum ersten Mal
auf dem Dach der Welt.
Er entfaltet seine Gebetsfahnen,
um den Göttern zu danken.
Für Long Dorje ist es das 14. Mal.
Lasst die Nepal-Flagge über
dem höchsten Berg der Welt flattern!
Sieg für Nepal!
Es war seit vier Jahren mein Traum.
Seit vier Jahren versuche ich,
auf den Mount Everest zu klettern.
Dieser Traum hat sich erfüllt.
Ich bin hoch erfreut.
Ich habe es
in den letzten vier Jahren
von Norden und von Süden aus
probiert.
Jetzt bin ich auf dem höchsten Berg
der Welt mithilfe meiner Freunde.
Meine Gebetsfahnen flattern im Wind.
Ich fühle mich nahe bei Gott.
Ich bin überglücklich.
Ich werde diesen Moment
nie vergessen.
Dorje, wie fühlt es sich an,
zum 14. Mal auf dem Everest?
Ich bin so glücklich.
Nicht nur ich.
Viele meiner Sherpa-Freunde
sind zum ersten Mal hier.
Wie viele Sherpas sind wir hier?
Acht.
Von acht ist es für sechs
das erste Mal.
Wangchu und ich
waren schon hier oben.
Es ist grossartig!
Eine tolle Leistung:
sechs neue Everest-Besteiger.
Und fast alle Expeditionsteilnehmer
sind auch hier.
Ich bin so glücklich.
Nach einer knappen Stunde
auf dem Gipfel
bereiten sich Sherpas und
Teilnehmer auf den Abstieg vor.
Gib mir viel Sauerstoff!
Den brauche ich für den Abstieg.
Ich brauche Power.
Okay.
- Okay.
Alle waren oben - bis auf Gianni,
der ohne Sauerstoff
immer noch unterwegs ist.
Auf 8'760 m.ü.M.,
direkt am Hillary Step,
treffen sie auf ihn
und Sherpa Mingma.
Auf dem Rückweg traf ich Gianni
am Hillary Step im Aufstieg.
Ich fragte, wie es ihm gehe.
Er sagte: "Okay."
Ich dachte, es ist nicht mehr weit
bis zum Gipfel
und Mingma hat Sauerstoff
für den Rückweg dabei.
Ich hatte ein gutes Gefühl.
Wenn Gianni auf den Gipfel kommen
würde, wäre das wunderbar.
Ich sah kein Problem,
da Gianni ja mit Sauerstoff
hätte absteigen können.
Aber im Nachhinein
war es ein Fehler.
Gianni und sein Sherpa Mingma
erreichen um 10 Uhr den Gipfel.
Gianni macht Fotos.
Alles scheint gut.
Die übrigen Expeditionsmitglieder
sind inzwischen im Lager 4 angekommen
Gezeichnet von über 14 Std.
Kletterei in dünner Luft.
Wir waren alle so glücklich,
auf dem Gipfel gewesen zu sein.
Wir waren fast die ersten
auf dem Gipfel.
Es war überwältigend.
Wir kamen zurück ins Lager 4,
begannen Eis zu schmelzen
und Wasser zu kochen.
Nach kurzer Pause steigen sie
ins Lager 2 auf 6'400 m.ü.M. ab.
Dorthin, wo die Luft
mit mehr Sauerstoff gesättigt ist.
Auch Long Dorje ist dabei.
Da bekamen wir einen Funkspruch,
dass mit Gianni etwas nicht stimmt.
Auch unser Bruder Mingma
sei in Schwierigkeiten.
Gianni beginnt auf dem Gipfel
zu schwanken und zu halluzinieren.
(Über Funk)
Im Abstieg, am Hillary Step,
hatte Gianni Schmerzen
in der Brust.
Er konnte nicht mehr gehen
und ich musste ihn
hinunterschleppen.
An schwierigen Stellen ging ich vor
und half ihm runter.
Es war unglaublich schwierig.
Ich dachte: "Jetzt wird er sterben."
(Über Funk)
Gianni bat alle,
denen wir begegneten,
um eine Sauerstoffmaske.
Sein Geist war verwirrt.
Er benahm sich wie ein Verrückter.
Vielleicht wusste er,
dass er sterben könnte.
Ich hatte ihm
seine eigene Maske gegeben,
aber die zerstörte er
mit seiner Hand.
Ich wollte ihm meine Maske geben,
aber die wollte er nicht.
Mingma schleppt Gianni weiter -
vorbei an aufsteigenden Bergsteigern.
Um 15.30 Uhr brechen Sherpa Dendi
und der deutsche Arzt Richard Brill
vom Lager 4 mit mehr Sauerstoff
und weiteren Medikamenten auf
und gehen ihnen entgegen.
Mingma schleppt Gianni weiter.
Sie sind inzwischen 20 Stunden
ohne Pause unterwegs.
Auf dem Südgipfel
ist es unglaublich steil.
Ich konnte Gianni kaum mehr tragen.
Ich dachte,
vielleicht sterbe ich jetzt auch.
Vielleicht sterben wir beide,
wenn das Seil reisst.
Es war sehr hart,
als wir beide an diesem Seil hingen.
So brachte ich Gianni runter.
Um 21 Uhr treffen der deutsche Arzt
Richard Brill und Sherpa Dendi
auf Gianni und Mingma.
Was in Gianni genau vorging,
weiss ich nicht.
Ich weiss nur, dass wir ihn
um 21 Uhr am Balkon getroffen haben.
Er war ansprechbar, aber
etwas unterkühlt und dehydriert.
Aber es ging ihm,
aus meiner Sicht,
den Umständen entsprechend
relativ gut.
Wir versuchten, ihn vom Balkon aus
runterzubringen Richtung South Col.
Gianni bekommt weitere Medikamente
und Sauerstoff.
Sie scheinen zu wirken.
Sherpa Dendi löst Mingma ab.
Ich brachte Gianni langsam
Schritt für Schritt runter.
Ich ging vor ihm.
Plötzlich stoppte er.
Ich musste uns
an dieser Position sichern.
Als ich das tat,
riss er mir das Seil aus der Hand.
Ich war über seine plötzliche
Veränderung sehr überrascht.
Gianni rutschte etwas
von der gesicherten Position weg,
in der wir uns befanden.
Ich konnte ihn
gerade noch auffangen.
Als ich dies tat,
war Gianni bereits tot.
Ich schüttelte ihn
und schrie seinen Namen.
Ich sagte:
"Gianni, komm! Wir müssen weiter!"
Aber er war tot.
Ich war schockiert in diesem Moment.
Es war das erste Mal
in meinem Leben,
dass ich einen Menschen
in den Bergen sterben sah.
Nie zuvor starb ein Mensch
vor meinen Augen.
Eine Gruppe von Sherpas bringt
Giannis Leiche auf den Südsattel.
Sherpa Mingma ist gezeichnet.
Fast 30 Std.
war er ohne Pause im Einsatz.
Ich bin sehr aufgewühlt
in diesem Moment.
Ich möchte nie mehr
in die Berge gehen.
Ich möchte meinen Job aufgeben.
Aber ich habe keine Alternativen.
Ich muss arbeiten,
um meine Familie zu unterhalten.
Ich muss arbeiten.
Wie lange willst du noch
in den Bergen arbeiten?
Noch ein bis zwei Jahre. Dann
will ich aufhören. Es ist genug.
Auch meine Frau will, dass ich
nicht mehr in den Bergen arbeite.
Die Expedition geht weiter.
Die Sherpas brechen das Lager 4 ab.
Auch Kari geht Richtung Basislager.
Er hat bis jetzt hier ausgeharrt
und alles koordiniert.
Unten im Basislager treffen die Teil-
nehmer nach ihrem Gipfelerfolg ein.
Erst in der Nacht haben sie per Funk
von Giannis Tod erfahren.
Sie versuchen,
den Tod von Gianni zu verstehen.
Der Mensch ist nicht gemacht
für diese Höhen, ohne Sauerstoff.
Er wollte es.
Es war sein Wille.
Leider Gottes musste er es
mit dem Leben bezahlen.
In den letzten Wochen
war das immer ein Thema:
mit oder ohne Sauerstoff.
Ich diskutierte mit Gianni
viele Stunden darüber
und ich war der Meinung, dass er
selber auch immer gehadert hat.
Er war nie so wie andere, die das
fast als Religion anschauen
und sagen: "Entweder so oder so."
Er liess sich immer
einen gewissen Spielraum offen.
Vielleicht wurde er sogar Opfer
seiner eigenen Kraft und Fitness,
denn manch anderer wäre
erst gar nicht so weit gekommen.
Was ging dir durch den Kopf,
als du von Giannis Tod hörtest?
Viel, viel Traurigkeit.
Das ist ...
Ich sagte es immer:
himmelhoch jauchzend -
zu Tode betrübt.
1:1 erlebt.
Es tut mir leid.
Aber es ist etwas,
das zu diesem Berg gehört.
Nicht nur zum Berg,
zum ganzen Leben.
Die Sherpas steigen am anderen Tag
noch einmal auf 7'900 m.ü.M. auf.
Sie wollen Gianni nicht
wie viele andere Tote am Everest
einfach liegen lassen.
Beim Big Stone haben sie ihm aus
Steinen eine letzte Ruhestätte erbaut
Während den zwei Monaten ist Gianni
zu einem Freund der Sherpas geworden.
Lasst uns unsere Mützen ausziehen
und eine Schweigeminute einlegen!
Wir legen immer eine Schweigeminute
ein für jeden der stirbt
und dann verneigen wir uns vor ihm.
Wir müssen beten.
Wir können uns nicht ohne Gebet
von ihm verabschieden.
Auf der Gegenseite des Everest,
am Pumori,
errichten die Expeditionsteilnehmer
zur gleichen Zeit
eine Gedenkstätte zu Ehren
ihres Bergsteigerkollegen.
Die Trauer und der Respekt
sind gross.
Der liebenswürdige Gianni
wird allen in Erinnerung bleiben.
Das ist ein sehr trauriger Moment
für uns.
Denn wir verabschieden uns von un-
serem Expeditionsteilnehmer Gianni.
Wir lassen ihn hier zurück
auf dem Südsattel.
Er war für uns
nicht nur ein Teilnehmer,
sondern ein guter Freund.
Er hat uns unterstützt.
Er war nett,
liebenswert und freundlich.
Er stand uns nah.
Dieser Moment ist sehr traurig.
Das ist alles, was ich sagen wollte.
Good bye!
Gianni ist der 211. Tote am Everest.
Er ist der Einzige im Jahr 2008,
in welchem 290 Menschen
auf dem Gipfel standen.
Die Expedition
neigt sich dem Ende zu.
Die Sherpas transportieren alles
Material
aus den Hochlagern ins Basislager.
Die Zeiten, als der Everest wie
eine Müllhalde aussah, sind vorbei.
Alles, was hier hoch kommt, muss
heute wieder runtergebracht werden.
Auch Long Dorje trifft nach
dem 14. Gipfelerfolg im Basecamp ein.
Thank you!
- You're welcome.
Wie oft will er noch
auf den Everest gehen?
Darüber habe ich
noch nicht nachgedacht.
Ich arbeite, solange ich mag.
Aber ich muss nicht unbedingt noch-
mals so viele Male auf den Gipfel.
Ich arbeite, solange ich
physisch dazu in der Lage bin.
Trotz aller Gefahr ist der Everest
ein lukratives Geschäft.
Wir opfern uns
für die harte Arbeit am Berg auf.
Wenn wir im Basislager ankommen,
probieren wir, den Schmerz und
die Schwierigkeiten zu vergessen.
Am nächsten Tag laufen wir
nach Hause und denken,
dass wir diese Arbeit
nie mehr machen werden.
Aber dann kommen wir in einem Jahr
wieder ins Basislager
und erinnern uns nicht mehr
an all die Anstrengungen.
Und alles geht wieder von vorne los.
Yaks und Träger transportieren das
umfangreiche Expeditionsmaterial
zurück nach Lukla.
Auch unsere Sherpas brechen auf.
In der Tasche, je nach Leistung,
4'500 bis 5'500 $.
Gutes Geld und viel Ruhm,
den sie nutzen können.
Wenn ich diese Kleider anziehe,
dann sehe ich gut aus.
Dann freue ich mich
auf den Heimweg,
auf die Ladies und das gute Essen.
Jetzt denke ich acht oder neun
Monate nicht mehr an den Everest.
Man braucht auch Zeit
für die Frauen.
Long Dorje kehrt zurück
in sein Bergdorf Thamo,
wo er wieder
zum einfachen Bauern wird.
Wie jeden Tag geht seine Frau
zur Arbeit hinaus auf die Felder.
Sie weiss nicht,
wann Dorje heimkehrt.
So erwartet den Everest-Helden
zu Hause eine herbe Überraschung:
Er steht vor verschlossener Tür.
Das ist das Geschäft der Sherpas.
Anstrengung, Gefahr,
gutes Geld und Erfolg.
Alles im Schatten des Everest.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Lilian Zbinden - 2020